[Musique]
elle trône majestueusement sur le bord
de la rivière au coeur du west hansell
rapide et fut un temps la plus grosse
papeterie au monde saute de fierté ici
elle a produit pendant plus d'un siècle
du papier glacé pour les magazines les
plus prestigieux mais à la fin du mois
dernier le coeur dow jones --le rapide à
ces dates 900 employés se sont retrouvés
à la rue presque du jour au lendemain
hamilton a passé 40 ans de sa vie à
l'usiné
il est encore sous le choc et 6,7
brad blâme les autorités pour leur
mauvaise gestion de la crise il en veut
surtout à dow jones 0,12
ils ont eu cette série web arabe lors de
la 12
autrefois il prospère où est-ce qu en
scène graffiti n'est plus aujourd'hui
que l'ombre d'elle-même déjà affectés
par la pandémie et la crise économique
elle engendrer
la fermeture de l'usiné et le coup de
grâce elle marque la fin d'une époque
pour des générations d'habitants de la
région
comme pour chaque dame accueille
aujourd'hui sans emploi après trente ans
à la papeterie review du boss
l'industrie du bois et du papier
c'est l'un des premiers employeurs ou
est ce qu'on s'a une économie de 28
milliards de dollars fait vivre près de
cent mille personnes
tu es de l'aîné c'est une affaire de
famille laura a repris récemment la
compagnie forestière fondé par son père
il ya près de 50 ans une entreprise
qu'elle a profondément transformé
n'hésitant pas à investir des millions
de dollars pour acquérir de la
machinerie ultra moderne mais avec la
fermeture de la papeterie
elle perd l'un de ses plus gros pire et
se retrouve aujourd'hui avec des tonnes
de bois invendus des dates importantes
et une dizaine d'employés
elle va peut-être devoir licencier
difficile dans ces conditions mais
combien républicains lors à notre temps
pourtant il ya des autorités le oui ce
concert est ce qu'on appelle un état clé
un état pivot des gens ici ont soutenu
barack obama en 2008 avant de voter pour
dormir
huit ans plus tard récupérer cet état
est donc crucial pour les démocrates
s'ils veulent pouvoir l'emporter en
novembre les sondages favorise
aujourd'hui joe biden
mais selon le politologue jean-luc mais
ce n'est pas gagné d'avancé
d'après lui les démocrates auraient tort
de tenir le oui ce qu'on sait pour
acquis car l'électorat ici surtout
rurales restent profondément
conservateur
en dépit de la crise bien peu de
républicains sont prêts à voter
autrement
l'aura de l'aîné par exemple n'a pas
changé de discours ni d'opinion
malgré la récession malgré les millions
de chômeurs malgré les 170000 mordu
coronavirus un soutien toujours
activement dans notre cas permettent
aujourd'hui sans emploi sans avenir dans
une région sinistrée tchad thomas que
reste lui aussi fidèle au président de
boeing france afin qu'ils mèneront au
bras à merten en revanche pas question
de voter jo et il est plein
aujourd'hui le parti démocrate de ne pas
répéter l'erreur des dernières élections
en négligeant luis qu'ont les électeurs
de la région le savent il détient la clé
du pouvoir comme 2016
la longue route vers la maison blanche
passe par le risque on s'est acharné
dinard de prévoir si arrêté deux fois
plutôt qu ici jean françois bélanger a
du canada